Головна православна святиня Донбасу, одна з трьох українських лавр - Святогірська.
Вона, як і Києво-Печерська та Почаївська, належить УПЦ, пов'язаній з Московським патріархатом.
Лавра розташована на правому березі Сіверського Донця, а місто Святогірськ - на лівому.
Міст, який з'єднував монастир і місто, підірвали у червні торік, напередодні окупації Святогірська.
У вересні місто звільнили. Та нині сюди вже не їдуть тисячі паломників -
"туристична перлина Донбасу" потрощена війною.
До монастиря Московського патріархату, який раніше був головною туристичною принадою регіону,
місцеві ставляться неоднозначно.
Лавра для мене - це святе, вона ж занесена в книгу…
Дякуємо, батюшка приїжджає, допомагає нам.
Взагалі так, це Московського патріархату.
Сюди і Янукович їздив, гнати б його поганим віником звідси…
Я сама росіянка і я проти цього "руского міра". Що вони нам тут зробили?
Ви знаєте, мені що Росія, що Україна - однаково.
У мені рідних дуже багато в Росії живе,
у мене батько в Росії і мама колись жила в Росії,
а потім переїхала сюди, батьки захворіли, і вона забрала нас, а батько помер давно.
Мені близькі і Росія, і Україна. Ось це, що відбувається, ця війна - ми в шоці всі.
Є і більш радикальні думки, але - не на камеру.
Що думають у самій лаврі - дізнатися нелегко. Журналістам тут не раді.
Ми не любителі балакати, дівчинко дорога моя!
Ні! Ми нічого не даємо даних!
На території лаври нам дозволили перебувати лише під наглядом місцевого охоронця.
Він повідомив, що клір монастиря не дає інтерв'ю.
У лаврі малолюдно, повсюди - сліди від обстрілів.
У дворі - могили загиблих через прильоти монахів.
Поки Святогірськ був окупованим, монастир залишався під контролем України,
утім не раз потрапляв під вогонь.
Священнослужитель лаври архімандрит Феофан, який відмовився спілкуватися на камеру,
не знає, чиї снаряди пошкодили обитель.
Також, на його думку, не варто засуджувати дії Росії.
Ще з 2014 року Святогірська лавра приймала біженців із прифронтових міст.
Нині тут проживають близько двох сотень людей.
Зокрема жителі довколишніх міст і сіл, які залишилися без даху над головою.
Ось рік при Росії просидів без роботи…
- Ось чуєте? Летить. Полетіло. Ось так сидимо і думаємо: хоч би не сюди гепнуло. Раз пронесло - добре.
Віталій з Ізюма і Сергій зі Слов'янська лагодять лінії зв'язку у монастирі.
Ось як чоловіки описують атмосферу у Святогірській лаврі.
Тут, як-то кажуть, "кожної тварі по парі".
Хтось, може, ближчий до Росії, хтось - за Україну.
Тут на це не дивляться. Ляпай, що хочеш, аби не робив нічого такого.
Ось у будь-яке село зайдіть: півсела за Росію, півсела за Україну - все!
Ще одна жителька лаври розповіла, як торік люди з монастиря намагалися перепливати річку,
щоб потрапити в окупований росіянами Святогірськ.
Деяких, за її словами, розстріляли.
Жінка не на камеру поділилася своєю версією, хто винний у цьому.
У 2014 році клір Святогірської лаври звинувачували у підтримці бойовиків так званої "ДНР".
Намісник лаври митрополит Арсеній називав війну на Донбасі "громадянською".
Це внутрішній конфлікт, це громадянська війна.
Війна виникає там, де недопрацьовують політики і дипломати.
Якраз недостатньо дипломатичного бажання почути один одного спровокувало цю війну.
У січні цьогоріч Арсенія позбавили українського громадянства.
Утім, на відміну від центральних і західних регіонів,
на Донбасі поки не йдеться про заборону пов'язаної з Росією церкви.
Святогірська лавра й надалі перебуває у безстроковій і безоплатній оренді УПЦ.
А це - один з небагатьох храмів ПЦУ на Донбасі.
Благословенний Боже наш нині і повсякчас і навіки віків…
Тут служить отець Віталій, який "в миру" працює оператором газорозподільчої станції.
Отак і живемо. Зранку прокинувся - руки-ноги є, голова на місці - слава Господу Богу. І вперед.
І оце люди збираються тут, тому що тут єдина кам'яна церква в місті Краматорську, наша.
Все інше - це жестянки, чи такі з ОСБ, якщо прилетить, там живих не залишиться.
А тут правило двох стін працює, бачите, тут одна стіна і друга стіна.
На Донеччині серед інших областей України - найбільше церков,
підпорядкованих УПЦ (МП). На користь ПЦУ ця ситуація поки не змінюється.
Жодна парафія в нашому регіоні не перейшла в українську церкву.
Ким би вони себе не називали: українською церквою, "єдиною православною",
чи як воно там себе називає, це була і є ФСБ-шна церква.
Отець Віталій - єдиний священник ПЦУ в Краматорському районі.
Чимало духівників виїхали з міста, що за 30 кілометрів від фронту.
Через це у отця Віталія - щільний графік.
Я займаюся похованнями наших полеглих воїнів по всьому району.
Якщо раніше це був Краматорськ, окреме місто було, то тепер це і є Краматорський район.
Тобто це майже 70 кілометрів в один бік.
І якщо хтось із наших воїнів загинув, то там більше нікому ховати.
Є московити, але зрозумійте, як це може виглядати,
якщо Москва вбила і Москву покликали відспівувати.
Не вкладається навіть у голові.
За словами отця Віталія, нині дедалі більше людей приходять до церкви.
Це мотивує священника продовжувати свою справу.
Це моя земля.  Мене сюди не завезли.  Я не населення.
Я громадянин цього міста. Я півроку був у ТРО.  Я і моя матушка.
Навчались, як боронити, як захищати,  як давати медичну допомогу.
Я цього не бажаю, але якщо треба буде, будемо захищати. Будемо до останнього.
Що ж до головної святині Донбасу - Святогірської лаври -
у ПЦУ закликають повернути її державі і сподіваються,
що скоро там звучатимуть молитви за український народ і ЗСУ.
У самій лаврі (не на камеру) кажуть, що будуть захищати обитель у законний спосіб.